en france la situation s'améliore
lentement la décrue est générale même si
la pluie a recommencé de tomber à cet
après midi le plan orsec a été levé vers
16h dans les alpes-maritimes c'est
maintenant l'heure du bilan
les intempéries ont entraîné de fortes
perturbations sur les routes et dans les
airs mais aussi de très très gros dégâts
matériels estimés par exemple à plus de
35 millions de fonds pour le seul
aéroport de nice côte d'azur reportages
sont grassement idée baume sans aéroport
nice c'est un peu le bout du monde mais
la direction l'a promis après pompage et
réparation les pistes et les terminaux
ouvriront demain à 6h01 le décollage
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
mais avec un confort limité surtout dû à
des problèmes informatiques
je ne dis pas qu'on aura tout la qualité
de service à laquelle sont au droit les
passagers on sort en mode dégradé
pendant encore quelques jours
les deux mahler au port est ouvert pour
tous les vols l'enregistrement restera
par exemple manuel pour les vols
internationaux dans cette crise
l'aéroport a perdu 50 mille passagers le
coût des dégâts va se chiffrer entre 30
et 40 millions de francs isolement par
la voie des airs en reste inédit à nice
mais c'est surtout la situation dans
l'arrière pays qui demeure préoccupante
problèmes d'électricité ou de téléphone
toute la journée les services techniques
ont dû intervenir pour encadrer ptt en
port en tout a été rejoint et puis il ya
les routes effondrées ces routes comme
la nationale 2 102 entre nice et digne
coupé en huit endroits différents
les services de la direction de
l'équipement ou repérer tous les points
critiques mais impossible de dire
exactement quand ces voies de
communication seront à nouveau
praticables il ne s'agit plus de
réparation mais de reconstruction le
conseil régional va débloquer 15
millions de francs ainsi que le conseil
général
des sommes qui vont servir en priorité à
la remise en état des routes
quant au train des pignes son avenir est
menacé la voie ferrée entre nice et
digne et dévastée elle risque de le
rester longtemps